[Music]
Californians passed a measure that
requires porn actors in Los Angeles to
wear condoms that's right they now have
to wear condoms that's the law the adult
film industry very upset with the law
but there's one company that thinks they
can help the voters have spoken measure
B has passed an adult film actors are
now required to wear condoms on all porn
shoots in Los Angeles County that's why
I opened bareback acres over 500 acres
of pristine screw ready plain and the
best part not a condom for miles because
it bareback acres there's no hats on our
jimmies no casings on our sausages no
cozies on their long necks no Trojans on
our halt no raincoats on our Wang's
and little dust jackets on our mr. omens
oh that last one doesn't work quite as
well smith-corona is a old branded
typewriter but metaphorically you get
the dust jacket being the condiment
typewriter being the Nutri need
unregistered skin-on-skin action come on
down to bareback acres only a short
drive from Los Angeles just north of raw
dog Kenya
[Applause]
[Music]
we got to take a drive up there Andy